but first here with reaction for such a
time as this kaylee mcenany along with
fox news contributor laura trump laura
will begin with you you know the one
issue of energy alone
i think and and i've said this before
your father-in-law did not get enough
credit for keeping prices of production
low the cost of filling our tanks had
never been lower heating and cooling our
homes had never been lower that means
the cost of transporting goods has never
been lower now everything is flipped and
flopped and it's never been higher
that's right well you heard joe biden
i'm happy to give out an apology earlier
about the paris climate accord he does
owe quite a few apologies sean and he
could probably start with the energy
workers remember who about a year ago he
lied to saying you're not going to have
to worry if i become president you're
going to keep your jobs what did he do
day one canceling the keystone xl
pipeline putting thousands of energy
workers out of a job and to your point
making sure that america was no longer a
net energy exporter no longer energy
independent like we were under president
trump we are now relying again on the
middle east on russia for our oil i mean
think about the implications of that
from a national security standpoint
you know forget just what it does cost
wise here in the united states but how
about also sean maybe he could apologize
i don't know to the family members of
the 13 soldiers killed during his
botched
departure from afghanistan how about an
apology to every single border state
border town i don't know basically every
city in town in america right now
because these people are overrun with
our fully open border he has not just
allowed people to come into america
illegally he and kamala harris invited
him in when they campaigned they said
come on doesn't matter where you're from
come on over our southern border you
don't have to follow any rules he could
also apologize maybe to the mom and pop
shops out there who've had to close
their doors now after they survived an
entire pandemic because of the supply
chain shortage that he himself and his
energy
policies have caused as you just pointed
out
how about the thousands of workers out
there thanks to his vaccine mandates who
are without jobs these were the heroes
of last year our front-line workers our
nurses doctors firefighters police
officers who now are without a job or
about to lose their job because of his
vaccine mandate he could also probably
apologize to our children because our
children are being indoctrinated all
across this country thanks to joe biden
and the democrats and what they believe
in with critical race theory a poison
that teaches our kids to judge one
another based on the color of their skin
not on the content of their character to
hate one another hate their country and
then to label their parents as domestic
terrorists for trying to find out what
their children are learning in school so
joe biden could offer up quite a few
apologies sean those are just a few he
could start with
oh i i look at this for example we're
looking at the video of joe taking a
little nap nappy today uh
kaylee and i know you have a young one
at home
so i know you know some people need to
sleep the president president trump used
to refer to him as sleepy joe
but he needed an aide to walk over and
wake him up
that's how bad it got and then he
apologizes to america so i'm not really
sure what i'm more embarrassed about our
president falling asleep and needing a
wake-up call or the president
apologizing to europe when we had the
lowest net emission standards under
donald trump
and he could have been lecturing them
about how we were able to accomplish
this
well both are embarrassing i can't say
this sean uh it appears in this video
here that some days apparently joe biden
naps longer in public than my daughter
blake who's upstairs naps on any given
day i mean that was a rather long time
to have your eyes closed during a huge
climate change summit remember sean this
is an existential crisis one that is
such a crisis that we need an 80 car
motorcade for joe biden we need john
kerry traveling on private jet with his
family emitting more co2 in just six
months than the average american driving
a vehicle it's such a crisis though that
joe biden in fact will nap through it
this is exceedingly embarrassing it's
why in the polling uh from nbc today
it's not just democrats underwater on
nearly every issue the economy
historically underwater
underwater more so than any time since
1991 but systemically people believe
this president's incompetent he can't
handle crises on each and every metric
of being able to lead the nation uh he
does not prevail and one thing i can say
never happened to me at the podium i
never stood there when republicans were
saying they wanted another nominee other
than president donald j trump uh jin
saki next time she goes to the podium
she'll be going there with more than 60
percent of democrats saying maybe we
should look into someone else as our
nominee for president wow what a state
of affairs for joe biden and donald
trump would say no you're going to pay
your fair share no we're not going to
sign bad trade deals anymore and europe
ended up doing everything donald trump
wanted and made better deals for the
american people kaylee thank you laura
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else